President Trump will be at his
mar-a-lago Resort in Florida for New
Year's Eve where he has been spending
time on the golf course despite enjoying
the Sunshine State the president is
preparing for winter in Washington as he
looks to rack up more legislative wins
on the heels of the historic tax reform
bill mr. Trump has already scheduled
meetings with Republican and Democratic
leaders while senior White House
officials work towards yet another staff
shake-up to prepare for the new year
chip Reid is in West Palm Beach with the
president chip good morning well good
morning the president says he wants to
tackle infrastructure and immigration
early in 2018 but for that to happen
both parties will have to back off their
entrenched positions and compromise for
the sixth time in seven days during this
holiday vacation the president was at
the Trump International Golf Club he
invited dozens of Coast Guard members to
join him next week the president will
head to Camp David with Republican
leaders to discuss the 2018 legislative
agenda in an interview with The New York
Times mr. Trump said he wants the two
parties to work together we want to fix
our roads our highways our bridges which
are in bad shape the president said so I
want a trillion-dollar infrastructure
plan I think it can be bipartisan at the
White House yet another staff shake-up
is underway this one focused on the
November midterm elections sometimes the
second year brings a tripling of
turnover James Thurber has studied the
presidency for more than four decades
and says the Trump administration's high
turnover numbers make it hard to be
productive it worries me about this big
turnover is that we don't know where
we're going with respect to policy we
don't know where we're going with
respect to relationships with the hill
but chief of staff John Kelly is adding
political staff including a new
political strategist in preparation for
what is sure to be a tough election
season Republicans currently hold a 46
seat majority in the House
but even with such a big margin many
Republicans are worried they could lose
control of the house next year
Alex chip Reid with the president in
Florida thanks chip